welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul
it's like he's here in the room with hey
hey
welcome to he's got this every time he
gets a little more piratey
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host
hearty mateys we're gonna watch the
biggest wtf questions
from dr strange and the multiverse of
madness from paul hey hey peter paul
paul
leave a like
and subscribe to him he's struggling
these days and he could use the help
awesome pity
don't worry paul after this reaction
i'll send you uh the thumb options i
have and be like which one do you think
is the best
okay so doctor strange in the multiverse
of madness takes us on a two-hour trip
through alternate universes in the
pursuit of getting america chavez the f
away from wonder i do
hide your kids because someone is gonna
have to raise them and i have to say
that i absolutely love the film i know
it's very divisive with people saying
the plot is messy and that there's some
disappointing aspects in terms of things
like the illuminati but i had a complete
blast sure
the big questions people have about the
character turns the plot holes and just
general issues that i see popping up
this video is going to include things
like why wonders kids are the same even
though vision isn't there where the
deadbeat bot is why reed is the dumbest
smartest man on earth why gamora didn't
cause an incursion and basically as many
questions as i can fit into a question
then please hit the green light and stop
the video if you enjoy our breakdown we
love you in every universe if you decide
to like and subscribe and with that
other way oh thank you for clicking this
now let's get into doctor strange too
okay so the first big thing i want to
discuss is why wonders kids are the same
in the eighth or eight universe when she
created them using magic in one division
surely they wouldn't be exactly the same
because the ones in the alternate
reality were conceived the old-fashioned
way whereas the ones in the hex just
showed up out of nowhere like those that
post full cam spoiler clips on youtube
two days before the film
now releases is pretty confusing unless
we take it that the westview ones
weren't who came first billy and tommy
are roughly about 10 years old i think
and therefore they would have had to
have been alive for that length of time
if they're real one division only
happened recently in terms of the mcu
timeline and therefore they would have
been created after the real ones in the
alternate universe if we look at the a38
in general they're far more advanced
than the 616 timeline and that's because
the snap never happened and therefore
they had five years of developing things
ah
good boy
haven't even had him show up in the 616
yet they most crucial five years ahead
but either way you slice it up there's
definitely a major time difference in
terms of how advanced they are right
right right kids are exactly the same is
explained in the movies
in another reality yes
[Music]
wonder would have likely dreamed about
her alton itself met her kids that way
and then subconsciously brought them to
life that's a really great call
really great call paul paul with the
great calls and then my thoughts fall
off the wall off the wall
yeah that was that was just really sad
because um of everything he said yeah
absolutely
dreaming of the kids at any point that
would give her perfect subconscious
material vision yes in order to concoct
the perfect replica children
i thought the kids are 10 years old yes
but this snap costs about like a five
year delay so they should be 15. it
should be like 15 years old then by the
time they get to this universe some
stuff is still not making any sense paul
yeah you're supposed to fix the movie
paul there was one theory that i think i
did get right about how she would have a
connection in some way to this other
multiversal wanda and which allowed her
to conjure up the kids uh in our earth
and so yeah
i would i went there mvp of the movie me
me we learned that in every other
reality that wonder is with their kids
whereas in the 616 she isn't so
therefore she would have definitely
encountered them at several points and
that kind of segues me into the next
point which is who is the daddy whilst
it would be easy to say vision
unfortunately and what does he do he
exists in the 838 universe and even if
he does the events of one division
definitely didn't happen
now we never meet tony stark in this
reality and therefore it's unlikely that
he actually exists there however we do
meet ultron bots which is why everyone
on the internet thought that tom cruise
could show up as superior iron man
however i don't think that these were
created by the character and instead i
believe that reed richards was the
person behind them dubbed the smartest
man
if he really is that then he probably
created them without the flaws and the
main ultron wouldn't carry aspects of
the personality that tony has so reid
likely figured it all out and because
ultron works he never tried to make
vision like what we saw in age of ultron
however even if the events of age of
ultron did somewhat happen and we got a
version of vision his time with wonder
would have been a lot different in the
movie we learned that the illuminati
killed thanos on titan and with this
happening it means that he never would
have gone to earth and ripped the mind
stone out of vision's head because this
didn't happen wonder would have never
grieved him created the hex and then
become the scarlet witch so ultron
working his intended changes the course
of the mcu and instead i think that
billion tommy's dad are probably just
some random guy it's ultron is a nice
message i suppose now well i don't know
i feel like it kind of contradicts the
rules a little bit there's not a tony
stark because the thing that made
america chavez special is the fact that
she's the only one in all the universes
there is only one america shop chavez
where with these multiverses a big part
of the point is that we all exist
just in different you know universes and
such so the tommy and billy thing i
think can be explained away like you
said with the snap
but tony stark though i think he would
have to exist in another universe and
even with what if as they established
was a tony stark in every universe maybe
that's it maybe this one's just long
since dead because apparently they just
want to kill him and everything everyone
is so yeah maybe we just died iron man
died off screen yeah dr strange too
we're going even further into a segway
from this to talk about why the
illuminati don't care about wander even
though strange tries to desperately warn
them that she's coming to matrix their
mouths because those two they say in
their reality strange is the biggest
threat after dreamwalking too much
supreme strange caused an incursion that
killed trillions of people because it
wiped out an entire reality this wonder
isn't as big of a threat even though we
as the viewers know how dangerous she is
this also kind of ties into why they
don't really care and at one point
captain marvel even says that they can
handle strange's little witch now
because all of the prior events like age
of ultron civil war infinity war end
game and one division never happened
their wonder is pretty de-powered it'd
probably be about age of ultron level
which is why they think they're fine
just sending lots of ultron bots after
her as she was pretty scared of them in
that film in the comics the arrogance of
hubris of the illuminati always led to
their downfall and they just don't see
wonder as a threat to them because
they're used to dealing with their one
day they've probably also looked into
other realities and have seen that in
ninety nine point nine percent of them
that she's just a full-time yummy mummy
spends most of her days making her kids
ice creams they're just like met all
those kids care about his eyes this
arrogance and underestimation of her is
why they weighed into the battle
completely unprepared and why reed even
tells her about black bolts power
because they're pretty idiotic a lot of
fans have said that it's a wasted
opportunity to introduce them like this
and i do kind of agree with them on some
level however the whole point of them is
to make us think that wanda has finally
met her match but she completely
overpowers them they are supposed to
represent the best team on one of the
best earths the fact that wonder turns
them into pasta just elevates the threat
wanda pasta well wait a minute i've seen
it twice now and mordo when he has first
seen and he's you know doing you know
another
exposition dump
explaining and talk about dreamwalking
and he understands what the scarlet
witch is and he's part of the illuminati
council you'd think that he would take
this situation incredibly serious you
had one job mortal he's the sorcerer on
the
illuminati he's the guy who'd be the one
to take this seriously yeah and if they
have the darkhold in this universe then
you think he would especially have
caused it elizabeth olsen kind of
referred to scarlet witch using this
other wanda as using the body like a bad
car in a way so it would decide that the
limitations that she's not in her body
she's in a less oiled version of her
body so it's not capable of doing as
much as our universe as wanda could do
you just imagine what our universe is
awana could do oh man if this other
wanda supposedly not as strong yeah it's
good that she wound up in this nerfed
ass wanda
so if the scarlet witch came through on
her own then that would be an even
nastier sequence of the illuminati oh i
know
it should have been like you are now
secreting the insides of you through
your
oh yeah it's gonna be like a cronenberg
movie
i know a lot of chatter online is about
how we waited years for professor x and
also john krasinski to show up as mr
fantastic to throw them away seems
pretty stupid but i believe in my heart
of hearts that all these characters will
be back in some form or another disney
of course acquired 20th century fox so
they'll likely be doing an x-men movie
soon we know that a fantastic four is
right around the corner captain carter
is confirmed to show up in season two
maria will probably be back in some form
or another in the marvels and black bolt
no yeah getting back in another earth so
the point of these characters justice
for black
seconds people was the illuminati's
inclusion disappointing
um it kind of depends if you're more
bothered about the cameos than what
they're supposed to represent but let me
know below exactly what you think
about it okay
find out here which massively pulls from
the comics in the source material what
happens is that two worlds start to move
towards each other on a collision course
that will destroy both of them this is
what the sacred worlds could look like
their fate or fight to the death until
they destroy the other reality which
massively ties into the secret wars
event this will likely be the big arc
that's coming around the corner all
right i'll discover that if one enters
another universe through dreamwalking
then it will start to create a footprint
there this will eventually cause an
incursion and that will destroy the
reality now this is very much why
strange and christine can't be together
even though the pair both have feelings
for one another christine if they were
to live in a reality together it would
eventually pull either the 616 or 838
towards it which would lead to a path of
destruction so they say goodbye at the
end with strange saying he loves it in
every universe i'm not i'm not right
you're crying now the reason that
america chavez and khloe it's okay to
cry because neither use the dark hole to
dreamwalk as we see claire cuts up in
reality into the dark dimension so she
can enter an axe at whatever universe
she wants to this way we also discover
that america is the only version of
herself that exists in the entire
multiverse urges being her means there's
no one for her to puppet in another
reality and therefore no incursions will
be caused okay so the incursions only
happen via the dream walking is that
what i'm getting at here is this is this
what i'm trying to understand i
think
so wouldn't wanda's involvement with
going to 838 and caused the incursion
yeah you would think unless it's also
got to do with like strange 616 being an
838 and maybe 616 is being pulled toward
him but it seems like dreamwalking
certainly exacerbates things but then
why don't the events of no way home
cause incursions because that was
originally supposed to come after this
what about the events of when loki and
sylvie sometimes go to other universes
you know
uh
it's fine because he's a god
[Laughter]
they're gonna have to come out with some
kind of pamphlet that just linearly
explains multiverse through all these
different connected stories somehow
asking the questions has led to more
questions but the multiverse has become
the x-men continuity of the emcee
there's actually another similarity with
the darkhold the book of ashanti and
america that we learn about in the film
we discover that the dark hold was
created for the scarlet witch and even
see statues of tommy and billy at the
fortress later on catholic created this
in every universe to bring about the
prophesized scarlet witch and that is
why there's a wonder and darkhold in
every reality however there's only one
book of ashanti because there's only one
america
so there could be more scarlet witches
when we see the pages of the shanty open
there's even a star there like what
america has now the reason gamora
doesn't expect
an endgame is because technically she's
from the same reality as the one that
died the events of loki hadn't really
transpired at that point and therefore
every time there was a branch timeline
created the tva shut it down they also
said in loki that end game was meant to
happen the way it did so they wouldn't
ever wipe out gamora she comes from 2014
in that reality and therefore when her
past self travels to the future it
doesn't create an incursion because
she's still from the 616. this is the
same with steve rogers who used the
quantum tunnel to travel back through
time in the 616 reality and it was from
here that he created a branch timeline
with peggy carter the way light his use
in the film also reflects at the worlds
which is why americas has different
colors in it because it's on a different
color spectrum whereas the 616 looks the
same throughout now a major criticism
i've seen about the film is that it's
wonders in one division personally i
don't really see that as being true and
in the post-credits scene we left her on
her own studying the darkhold looking
for her kids we pick up with her
studying the darkhold looking for her
kids and though it's getting compared to
daenerys from game of thrones i think
there's actually way more here wonder is
also corrupted by the darkhold which is
why she's not really that reasonable
anymore and if you can accept that
sinister strange was turned evil by it
then you can accept that wonder was too
i'm telling you you'll accept it
remember this is a book that prophesies
the rise of the skull witch and this it
was written purely with the intent of
corrupting hair in order to turn her
into someone that would really entire
multiverse yeah i mean a lot of people
do feel that way while i think there's a
middle chunk it doesn't feel
entirely disjointed to me to not fill in
that middle chunk ourselves because
there's clearly a time jump here from
the post-credits scene of her doing the
darkhold which we know was not a no-no
you don't want to do darkhold then she
hears her children so she's been really
experimenting with it and now she really
understands that there's a possibility
to somehow attain her children and the
dark holds evil i don't know i feel like
the movie laid it out pretty clearly
i thought it made sense i feel like
there are scenes and supplemental
moments that you could show but i feel
like the progression makes sense coming
out of one division you know you could
easily extrapolate that this is where it
might go and you can easily see the road
that led us here if you look back at
that show yeah i feel like the whole
stinger of one division is supposed to
suggest a sinister turret
now who dying at the end could also
explain how we're getting the disney
plus series i get the house of harkness
at the end of one division wonder
trapped agatha in an illusion but with
her apparent death at the film's clothes
we could see agatha breaking out of this
series the film very much brings the
best argument for rwanda death but we
could definitely see her back at some
point good point also does this with
strange he very much grows as a
character throughout the film berlion
christine says that he always has to be
the one holding the knife which is
echoed by her a38 counterpart however
come the end of the film he finally
decides to hand things over to america
rather than taking her power he no
longer has to be the one holding the
knife and instead can now trust others
he did let tony stark sacrifice himself
it's true it's cold he wasn't holding
the knife then that's true he let tony
hold the knife for thanos what a
generous guy so what's this whole thing
about you always have to do everything
yourself with
us there's that one time if you'll
recall i got out of the way so the toad
he could break
back
so i don't know what you're talking
about right him fixing the watch in the
final few scenes also represents a lot
of things for the character the first
film ended with strange staring at the
watch in the sanctorum accepting that he
was broken but still powering through it
however this film ends with him
repairing it showing how he's very much
overcame the internal issues he had over
losing christine we're also introduced
to claire in the post credit scene who
actually ends up becoming his wife in
the comics i guess anyway
another one opens and it's a great way
to take the character now lastly does
wonder get back on the lunch box nope
and that's the video we didn't cover
this one as we already have a big
breakdown on it and that will be linked
on screen right now if you want to go
and check it out you're a good man
paulie good man thank you paul what i
learned is that you can't have rachel
mcadams so instead he's getting an
upgrade to charlie's there and it's a
downgrade depending on your preferences
so tell us in the comments below is
charlie's there and an upgrade for you
or a downgrade or right on the money
a lateral move
[Laughter]
guys subscribe to heavy spoilers he
deserves to be at a million subscribers
sooner than later hit that like button
and
yeah this slips one more question
but i answered a couple of really big
ones yeah you answered questions to
things i didn't really have a question
about it
it does answer that question providing a
valuable service questions you didn't
even know were there
hey let's do a page
tyler hague tyler my man
i want to go through the multiverse to
see all the different tylers that are
out there also versus tyler in one
universe tyler
is the president of the united states
and he lets everyone have teddy bears
boom like wow you're the greatest
president ever while everyone demands
healthcare benefits and then in another
universe tyler is a postal worker
constantly late to delivering mail and
gets fired from his job leading to him
having to room in his mother's basement
and then another universe tyler is a ufc
cage fighter
who then faithfully gets injured rushing
to the hospital has a brain aneurysm
it's not pleasant and there's this other
universe where tyler he's just walking
and then gets hit by a car forever just
in a loop it's like that meet joe
blackmon
and another universe tyler is sleeping
then a guy comes in oh no drop kicks him
in the head brain aneurysm
a fixed point and then at another
universe tyler's taking a shower then
his skin melts oh no the water becoming
too hot there's nothing happening hot
water universe
i'm sorry for the events but in our
universe
you get to live
and not get ostracized by the united
states citizens of america absolutely
not get accepted that's right dude so
thank you for being you tyler
hey
[Music]